Jimmy Butler we're gonna have to begin
with the obvious which is a new look for
you before we started you said this was
your Emo stage what does that look like
for you
emotional right now a lot have gone on
in the past week
with basketball so you know I'm into
wearing all black and then my emotions
the Bucks of tamper your show if you can
name those emotions just that you have
gone through within the past week what
are those emotions so much has happened
I was excited
and then angry
and then sad and then excited again and
then pissed off
and then
sad again and now I'm excited you just
can't tell because I'm not smiling but
I'm very happy
okay so let's talk a little bit about
this roller coaster emotions that I'm
sure you have felt starting with
obviously the news of the Damian Lillard
trade that he will be going to the bucks
but what was your just initial reaction
when you saw that and then who do you
direct those emotions to I don't tell
anybody how I feel I just handle it
accordingly but I I am having for dang
to to be somewhere where you know he's
wanted where he has a chance to win a
championship
I'm also happy for Adrian Griffin
because
you know to be a first year head coach
and have some guys like you have
um good for you but you know I'm still
going to be me I'm gonna go beat Dame
Giannis and Adrian Griffin
um on our way to a title like I've said
every single year and I mean it this
year like a minute every other year but
um the emotions we got to use that it's
got to feel us and um we'll go get it
done now you know going off of that I
know how passionate you are about
winning and I know how much you hate
losing how often have you thought about
the NBA finals from last season
not often at all because there's nothing
that I can do about it now
I let my team down the organization down
so I gotta get his back there and I
gotta I gotta win it I gotta figure out
a way we have to figure out a way
and um I will slash we will and
I don't know we'll catch everybody by
surprise once again
um but you know we're not we're not
running from anybody I don't think
anybody's running from us so we're gonna
see where we end up at coming June well
I mean after that trade fell through the
narrative for some became it's another
year that Jimmy won't have much help so
I'm just going to ask plainly do you
feel like you have enough help to go win
a championship to me
sure do sure do
um we got a great group of guys
um
I just like number 22 for the heat I
think he
he's gotten better at basketball through
the years and the guys that he has
around him is more than enough to win
and we will do just that
and like I said you know we're gonna get
all the oh they got lucky and did this
they got lucky and did that happen to
stance
but we're going to take all the luck and
all the happenstance that we can get
thank you